Từ từ chỉ vụ và mình chính vừa kiếp ban hành công điện số chính biết chính về việc,
đảm bảo sắp xếp các đơn vị hành chính và vận hành bố hình tụ trước chỉ quyền địa phương 2,
cóp thông xuất hiệu quả. Từ từ nếu cầu các bộ ngành địa phương,
hình chương hoàn tất cả những vụ lực sau, bảo đảm mô hình chính thức đi vào họ tổ hiệu quả
tất cả một một tháng bẩy. Theo tổng hợp đến thời điểm này, nhiều địa phương vẫn trận trẻ trong việc công bố
tụ tu khánh chính, cấp chữ ký số, tai khoảng công vô bố chỉ trụ sơ mới và chỉ trải trị đổ cho cả bộ
tụ tu khóu quản dưới năm 2019. Thủ tưởng yêu cầu các địa phương phải hoàn tất công bố tụ tu khánh chính,
công thai trụ sơ, đường dây nóng, cấp đầy đủ chự ký số và tải khoảng trức
các hiện thống tập hần cán bộ. Cái nối cộng dịch vụ công quốc gia và các cơ sơ giữa
trên nành chập nhất trước này, má mời thẳng sấu, cùng với đó các địa nhên sắp xem trụ sơ,
cơ sơ và chất cho các sả mở và dài quý tịt tợi chính xác với cán bộ đi việc xong rất nhập.
Thủ tưởng nhấn mạnh, đây là nhận vụ cấp bán phải được chiến khai khẩm trường đồng bộ để bảo đảng vụ
vụ cụ gửi dân dân nghiệp linh tục hiệu quả trong quá trình chuyện xong mỗi mới.